[Music]
foreign
yes
others will measure you with the same
Rod you use to measure them
[Music]
the devil steals what you've earned
one should not eat meat where one earns
one's bread
[Music]
too many arms and the saint will be
suspicious
[Music]
you can only take out of a bag what was
already in it
[Music]
never put off till tomorrow what you can
do today
a dog bitten by a snake is afraid of
sausages
if marriage were a good thing there
would be no Witnesses
there's no good that lasts forever or
evil That Never Ends
[Music]
water can break the hardest Stone
they who want everything lose everything
[Music]
God helps those who wake up early
beauty lies in the eye of the beholder
[Music]
hope is the last thing to die
friends are friends business is business
[Music]
The Grass Is Always Greener in your
neighbor's yard
necessity makes the frog jump
[Music]
past Waters can't move a mill
the one in a hurry will have a raw meal
foreign
walls have ears
[Music]
hell is crowded with people with good
intentions
when the cucumber is small it is easier
to bend
[Music]
better preventing than fixing
in a closed mouth flies can't enter
Coral between a husband and wife keep
away
to air is human to repeat your error is
foolishness
[Music]
some bad things come for good
don't put the cart before the oxen
[Music]
the cheapest things are the most
expensive ones
the worst blind person is the one who
refuses to see
if you want it done do it yourself
otherwise ask someone else to do it
[Music]
for those who know how to read a DOT may
be a letter
[Music]
plays with pigs will eat with them
if counsel were a good thing it wouldn't
be given but sold
if you can't beat them join them
Goodwill makes the road shorter
[Music]
he who sings throws sadness away
the trees with the most leaves will not
produce the best fruit
[Music]
warns of danger is a true friend
one who does not look ahead remains
behind
[Music]
there's always an old pair of slippers
for the tired feet
you cannot cover up the sun with a sieve
in the house of a blacksmith the
ornaments are made of wood
[Music]
the beginning and the end there is
always the middle
[Music]
the cake is not for the baker but for
the eater
[Music]
pay love with love
Dirty Laundry should not be washed at
home
[Music]
every mishap is funny as long as it
happens to someone else
[Music]
united we stand divided we fall
little strokes fell Great Oaks
better to ask the way than to go astray
the shoemaker's son always goes barefoot
an empty sack cannot stand upright
the safe person dies of old age
an idle mind is the devil's workshop
sing and scare away your woes
don't judge a book by its cover
there's no use crying over spilled milk
there are evils that come for good
he who sees the face does not see the
heart
[Music]
those who do not risk do not have a meal
if you're not willing to take a risk
don't complain when you get nothing
grain by grain the hen fills her belly
each monkey on its own branch
[Music]
for someone wise half a word suffices
a stay-at-home Saint Works no miracles
[Music]
when you get married you need a house
don't hang your hat higher than you can
reach
money alone can't make you happy
don't carry all your eggs in one basket
don't call the alligator a big mouth
until you have crossed the river
the old man with a torn sleeve never
Dishonored anyone
a sleeping Fox finds no meat
if you run the Beast catches you if you
stay the beast eats you
those who play with fire will get burned
as you make your bed so you must lie on
it
a faint heart never one a fair lady
Love Is Friendship set on fire
all cats are dark at night
[Music]
He Who Walks In The Rain gets wet
in a house without bread everyone shouts
and no one is right
[Music]
if you expect something in return it's
called business not love
[Music]
you may be someone to the world but you
are the world to someone
place your time and energy on someone
who will add sunshine to your life life
is too short to waste on the wrong
someone
[Music]
the most beautiful thing in the world is
to live each second as if it were your
last
work hard in silence let your success be
your noise
[Music]
you want something you have never had
you must be willing to do something you
have never done
[Music]
the greatest pleasure in life is doing
what people say you cannot do
[Music]
never give up on a dream just because of
the time it will take to accomplish
time will pass
[Music]
you don't have to be great to start but
you have to start to be great
[Music]
start an affair with a woman who will be
grateful to you for it
[Music]
a River cuts through Rock not because of
its power but because of its persistence
[Music]
winners never quit and quitters never
win
[Music]
you have to go through the worst to get
to the best
[Music]
don't do your best do whatever it takes
work until your brain forgets and your
body remembers
[Music]